so as we were going into production for yesterday's
show, Robert Mueller spoke, Robert Mueller
issued a statement, he spoke publicly for
the first time since the publication of the
Mueller report and it very quickly became
a braking and major story in and of itself,
but also because of the reactions that it
triggered from President Donald Trump himself
from Fox news anchor, Bret Baier, all of which
we'll get to a little bit later.
But the bottom line is that it was announced
yesterday that Robert Mueller would be issuing
a statement special prosecutor.
He ended, uh, indeed did issue that statement.
He spoke publicly and he confirmed that he
could not clear and has not cleared President
Donald Trump of criminal wrongdoing.
Period.
Now, a lot of my audience hopefully read the
Mueller report and if you read the molar report,
nothing that Robert Mueller said yesterday
would come as a surprise to those who were
operating on the basis of what the bar letter
said.
For example, anyone who fell for no collusion,
no obstruction, uh, if you bought into that
narrative, then when Robert Mueller yesterday
said, if we could have cleared Trump, we would
have cleared Trump.
Meaning we didn't clear Trump because we couldn't
clear Trump.
That may have actually been newsworthy to
you.
Robert Mueller saying, if we had confidence
the president did not commit a crime, we would
have said.
So.
The reason the report doesn't clear Trump
of obstruction of justice is because Robert
Mueller could not clear Trump of obstruction
of justice.
And then again, Robert Mueller pointing out
that the Justice Department won't charge Trump,
but that there are other options again referring
to impeachment and many Democrats, uh, as
a result of Robert Mueller's statement yesterday
saying, now it is time to start that impeachment
debate on the floor of the house.
But we will get to that a little context for
what Robert Mueller said.
When a subject of an investigation obstructs
that investigation or lives to investigators,
it strikes at the core of their government's
effort to find the truth and hold wrongdoers
accountable.
Let me say a word about the report.
The report has two parts addressing the two
main issues.
We were asked to investigate the first volume
of the report details numerous efforts emanating
from Russia to influence the election.
His volume includes a discussion of the Trump
campaign's response to this activity as well
as our conclusion that there was insufficient
evidence to charge a broader conspiracy.
And in the second volume the report describes
the results and analysis of our obstruction
of justice investigation involving the president
and the order appointing me as special council
authorized us to investigate actions that
could obstruct the investigation.
We conducted that investigation and we kept
the office of the acting attorney general
apprised of the progress of our work and as
set forth in the report after that investigation,
if we had had con confidence that the president
clearly did not commit a crime, we would have
said so.
Mueller also announced that he's retiring,
resigned, resigning his position as special
prosecutor retiring from the Justice Department,
sort of very formally ending his role as special
prosecutor.
So on the one hand, major breaking news, special
counsel saying, I can't clear Trump.
On the other hand, nothing's surprising at
all.
If you read the Mueller report, uh, if instead
of listening to the William Barr or to Trump
or Trump's kids or Fox News or Sean Hannity,
you would know already that the president
was not cleared of obstruction by Mueller's
investigation.
Bottom line, in all likelihood, Donald Trump
committed the crime, multiple counts of obstruction
of justice.
Robert Mueller did not indict, uh, for political
reasons, for technical reasons, pointing out
that the Justice Department has this policy
of not inditing sitting presidents, but pointing
out again, that there are other remedies available.
Uh, and there are some who are interpreting
this as a signal from Robert Mueller to Nancy
Pelosi to whoever that might be in a position
to actually deal with impeachment seriously.
That is the only path forward if you want
to hold Trump accountable for what appears
to be, uh, um, uh, obstruction on, from my
recollection of the Mueller report, eight
of 14 possible obstruct obstructive acts,
I believe is how they were referred to in
the Mueller report.
So on impeachment, there's some momentum here.
There, there is a public statement from Robert
Mueller.
People they're going to prison.
Um, let's move forward.
And I have been saying for awhile now that
there are numerous strategic benefits for
Democrats to starting impeachment debate on
the floor of the house.
I do not believe that you going to remove
Trump, but I am going to outline later on
in the program what the advantages to doing
this would be.
And I think they're, they, they are clear.
I know that there is a contingent of the left
which says, you know, it could backfire if
Democrats start impeachment proceedings on
the floor of the house.
It could reinvigorate Trump's base.
It could be a distraction from 2020 Democratic
candidates talking about ideas and policy.
Uh, I don't believe that.
And I'm going to outline that for you a little
bit on in the program.
Start the impeachment debate.
Get things going, get testimony from witnesses,
expose the content of the Mueller report to
the American people, which as I told you yesterday
and the day before and the day before that
most Americans have not read the molar report.
Most Americans don't understand what is in
the molar report.
Uh, and it would be extremely beneficial to
get that out in front of as many Americans
as possible.
And by the way, side note, Mueller and his
statement also did again say Russia was working
through wikileaks for the publication of a
lot of the stuff that ultimately was published
that was illegally obtained by Russia.
Um, that is something that people on the right
and left, we're denying for years, which Mueller
has now repeated and provided evidence for
in his report.
Not a peep, not a peep from all the people
who said there's no way wikileaks would ever
be involved in anything like that.
Oh, well they were, they were.